có trường tị mang tầng xai số của các
thật số
muốn đến xai số về lối thì không có đậm đấy
xai số tội tổ phát đau
chết tờ rả chị trung mấy
và xai số tội lối
của yêu lên đẹp
chết tờ rả chị trung mấy của yêu lên đẹp
những một chăng bình chăng bình chăng bình chăng bình
đúng như cộng tất
cộng lối cộng lối
đẹp tài y
chết tờ
cơ nộ sẵn liên y trung mấy
dân một chăng bình chăng
đau rộn
đẹp tổ vụ đầy
đẹp
em gì này
bằng khu bếp của này
đúng không phải bộ
chết tờ
yêu lên đẹp
dân một chăng bình chăng bình chăng bấy
đẹp tờ
phục phát l tuv
comeo
ch Щ kh Completely
womb
chết t acord
phục pháp
xi do
bởi bằng khưc
chẵn
hậuية
A Tổ Tệ
Bỏ hướt thì không thể nắng không đưa nay được có một số em sợ em ơi thấy ở nhà mình bắn tổ em
Cứ học đừng có lĩnh ý nếp nơi mời
Cái có theo không
Bỏ hướt bỏ lĩnh
Tương lời
C'est khác
Nếu em thấy ngôn vào đi có khăn tỷ thấy
Về đổi của thầy